thank you yeah I'm like super excited to
be here because um this seminar was
really what got me into HCI so I was a
grad student I was a PhD student here
from 2006 to 2012 and as Michael
mentioned I did not start out in HCI but
taking the HCI intro class and and going
to these seminar talks really inspired
me to get in HCI so I actually had
several of my bucket list dreams one of
them in grad school was to give a google
Tech Talk and the other one was to be
invited to give a a seminar talk here so
I've checked those things off so now now
my life is complete for the very far or
something no there's more stuff I want
to do alright so who wants to learn
programming nowadays so a lot of people
do most obvious population if you want
to be a software engineer these are
great jobs they're everywhere
internationally you have to learn
programming if you want to be a data
scientist which is a really fast growing
role in industry now it involves your
basic programming skills in fact if you
want to be a scientist or engineer in
any field you have to learn programming
so this is one of my best friends from
childhood name's Kevin he's on the left
here you think that he's an
oceanographer so you think that he's out
on the ocean doing all this glamorous
science stuff but he only spends
probably a few percent of his time doing
that and most of his time he's hunched
over in front of the computer processing
and analyzing and graphing data so
scientists and engineers of all stripes
now want to learn programming even more
broadly now people in all sorts of
business and non-technical roles are
flocking to learn programming both in
college and also on the job we have a KY
paper coming out in the KY conference in
a few months
where we surveyed and interviewed a lot
of non-technical people at large
technology companies asking them about
their motivations for learning
programming and and you could read up on
that on my website there has been a lot
of excitement around learning
programming in school recently so
there's all these initiatives about
coding code org an hour of code and all
stuff abouts in school settings so in
school you have things like one-on-one
tutoring where people are drawing
diagrams and and kind of tutoring you in
a very high-touch way you have pair
programming and peer learning where
you're in the computer lab and you're
you're working together and these
lab settings you have one too many
tutoring so you have a you have computer
labs with maybe 20 or 30 students and
you have an instructor or TA walking
around assisting people and one of my
colleagues Marquez Dao recently released
this book that surveyed over 300 papers
in the computing education literature
which mostly looked at techniques and
tools for helping people learn
programming better in a school setting
so there's a lot of really great people
working on improving improving and
studying this what I'm interested in is
a far larger population and it's
observation the majority of people who
want to learn programming or learn
anything for that matter are not in
school so since we're out of university
we think of learning as you know k12 or
college but in fact there are people of
all ages and stripes all around the
world who want to learn these really
practical skills like programming but
they don't have access to in-person
resources so this isn't this is Hamilton
62 years old she's one of the user
survey respondents so she's currently
working as a document assistant in a law
firm so she's essentially a typist and
now she's been learning online using
various resources such as mine and she
writes I wanted to learn computer
programming
so it's establish a new career and have
some independence so that somebody's
over 60 who is in a job and wants to
start pivoting into something perhaps
more technical and perhaps more or
lucrative but the most frustrating
aspect of learning online is I do not
have a teacher on a face-to-face basis
such as in a classroom environment and
this is impeded me greatly so kind of
survey responses like hers
representative of some of the
frustrations people are feeling when
they have to learn online that they
don't have access to all these great
things that we take for granted in a
formal educational setting so the
central challenge that motivates the
work I'm presenting today is the
following question it's how can we scale
up the benefits of face-to-face learning
to the rest of the world and I want to
start with programming as an exemplar
because it's an example of us really
cognitively complex and also a fairly
in-demand skill set but these ideas that
I talked about may generalize to
learning other sorts of complex skills
at scale as well so throughout the talk
I'm going to touch on this theme of
what about going beyond just programming
the way I want to I want to think about
this this journey throughout the hour is
this design space with two dimensions
with scale and one axis and with
fidelity on the other so on one extreme
there's face to face which is extremely
high fidelity but very low scale because
you have to be they're color coded in
person and on the other extreme we have
static online materials this is learning
from reading a PDF or reading somebody's
lecture notes they put online or a
PowerPoint or YouTube video and the way
I approach my work in the past few years
is to first get inspired by the best
practices and face-to-face learning by
the things that we know to work
effectively face-to-face and then think
about designing systems for scale from
day one to overcome these limitations of
face to face and then finally leveraging
the scale to make discoveries and then
to drive the next steps in the next
projects so the outline of this talk is
following is I'm gonna first present a
visualization platform and then talk
about two specific social learning
systems built on top of that and then
conclude with some discussion of future
work before I start talking about the
system's which comprise most this talk I
want to do a kind of getting a little
bit of theory of learning so there's a
lot of literature out there that shows
that learning programming is really
really hard and for those of you in the
audience who have been programming for
years it's easy to forget how difficult
of a task this is for for many novices
and and you know one way to summarize
the essence of why learning is hard on
one slide is the following is that you
have a learner here they're writing some
code so this is Python but it could be
any language they have to compile and
run the code and then this gets output
something gets output on the screen so
in a mainstream text-based language
you're writing text and you're
outputting tax what you have to do is
stare at this input output pair so
there's three print statements here and
there's three lines printed and if you
think what just happened in the computer
to bring this input that I wrote to this
output you know what why did this happen
and this is something that's so basic
that those of you here who are expert
programmers don't even think of it this
is a subconscious and this is the mental
model of what happened they can
there's three global variables and their
five lists that you should point to list
this is a nested list so this fully
explains this input/output pair this is
what people do all the time the problem
here is it is completely wrong it's
completely incorrect mental model and it
turns out that novices come with all
these misconceptions about how
programming works based on prior
knowledge mostly about prior knowledge
of math or prior knowledge of kind of
folk interactions with computers so we
see this in physics education also
people the the real world in physics is
very different than the idealized F
equals MA world that you learn in in
physics class one of my colleagues and
his dissertation participation
documented 162 of these misconceptions
in this giant table the cool thing I did
is he not only wrote the text on
amaizing they also wrote the primary
sources of the the primary literature
that studied them so here's two examples
they're sources one example is
assignment moves a value from one
variable to another when in fact it
actually copies so if you say something
assigned something else that actually
makes it copy instead of moving and the
other one is objects nowhere refer to
them so like the pointers point from the
object to the thing that is referring to
them and those are both false so if you
know programming those that seem silly
but it's well documented the beginners
have all sorts of these these sorts of
misconceptions about how the computer
works behind the scenes the good news is
that visualizations and diagrams are
really effective at clarifying and and
and remedying these misconceptions so if
there's only somebody that drew a
diagram for you and showed you how this
worked inside the computer then the act
of studying these visualizations for
novice is what happens that it reduces
extraneous cognitive load so when you're
learning and you just you don't have
pictures and there's all this hugged
load and think and try to comprise these
diagrams yourself and not enough extra
load to actually learn so if you see
diagrams in front of you it's a it's an
effective way to kind of start
solidifying these these mental models
and your long-term memory so in fact in
this case this is the right picture here
is that they're actually only two lists
and they're shared so this is the Python
symmetric so it's not obvious if you
haven't learned Python before so the
underpinnings of my work kind of
basically the scope of
the project I'm going to present are of
the following is that first is that
building these proper mental models are
foundational they're prerequisites for
learning anything more advanced so
before you can get to understanding how
to do software engineering or work on
teams or do idioms or design patterns
you have to really know nuts and bolts
what is the computer even doing with my
code well you're just basically
scrambling and and having those
misconceptions second one is that's
studying these pre-made visualizations
is an effective first step before say
the teacher makes you draw your own and
this is um this is an effect called a
worked example effect and educational
psychology which states that having
example shown to you first
with good explanations well is a lower
cognitive load activity again that will
allow you to spend more of your
attention on learning rather than on
trying to construct yourself first so
there's value in seeing these diagrams
for for novices and finally these if
visualizations are most effective for
early stage novices people are just
learning and that basically what happens
you wean off them over time so as expert
programmers here you don't draw
visualizations for every single thing
this stuff happens in your mind the
schemas are quite different but it turns
out that that this is a a really
important foundation for novices okay so
we know that visualizations are
important so how do we generate them so
the traditional way down right those is
to have humans draw them so humans draw
these visualizations all the time when
you're tutoring on a blackboard or just
on paper and the question here that I
started with is how do we scale this up
specifically here is how can computers
automatically generate these
visualizations and and how will people
end up using them so to start investing
this question I've been working for the
past few years on this visualization
platform called Rosetta that
automatically generates these diagrams
so this site is more commonly known as a
Python tutor because the domain name I
registered years ago and but now it has
grown to many languages out and some
more coming soon so this is kind of a
language independent site by this point
but it's just simply a web based thing
where you can just write or copy and
paste code in so you just write your
code this is the code from the exact
code from the demo you hit the visualize
button and then that sends the code to a
sir
the server has some machinery to
instrument your code analyze it running
in a sandbox and then it produces a
value trace of everything that happened
when your code was running and that
brings you back to an interactive
visualization on the web so you write or
copy code here and then it goes makes a
round trip and you see something like
this so it looks like a visual debugger
there's an arrow here there's a slider
there are buttons and when you click the
forward button or when you when you
slide it will run the first line of code
is x equals ABC and then python the
model is there is a global frame here
there's X and the points to a list and
then second line y equals x this is the
line that's not obvious if you haven't
learned Python before because several
things might happen but if you actually
run it you'll see that they both point
to the same thing and then as you keep
running the diagram starts evolving and
and there's the print out down here like
the terminal you can also go backwards
there is actually no trick here because
all the code has already been run on the
server and processed so this is just a
thing we can slide back and forth so
this thing has been deployed for a few
years but I'm hardly the first person to
think about the idea of automatically
generating these diagrams so my
colleague has this great survey paper
serving dozens of these systems from the
past few decades this is for Mozilla 2
which is the language I've never used
but you know it's shows code shows the
arrows it shows these things they all
look kind of feel like same flavor what
he found in survey was that from a
systems perspective these were all
custom built with one language in mind a
modulo two and ones vocabulary one
static set of diagrams the practical
implications of that is that they get
really obsoleted really fast over time
so I don't think anyone teaches in this
language anymore so as a result these
things are really prototypes made for
demonstrating sort of visualization
ideas there certain pedagogical ideas
and none of them have scaled beyond just
their original use site and he ends is
served my colleague ends the survey
paper with that going to really like
which is building a system that sees
genuinely widespread adoption may
require departure from the prevalent I
made a prototype for my thesis loaded
system development which is something I
was guilty of myself as well in my PhD
so knowing that I wanted to you know I
didn't wanted to make another thing that
just
you know the same ideas before I really
wanted to design for scale so that's the
theme but throughout the stuff yes gems
just about time that that work was done
I mean the web had barely existed if you
had done your just repo Python on the
web and it just happened to catch arms
you think oh yeah I think just that you
hadn't think about scale designing if it
sure didn't work out it was I think is
that that that timing thing I mean
timing of web obviously coincided with
that and there was I think there's a lot
of code design as well of once a story
taking off a bit thinking about some of
these design points helped it gain
momentum but yeah I mean this would not
have been possible without the web right
if we were on you know whatever 286
assembly language is probably gonna work
that's right so time so you've preempted
my personal point was the fact that this
came at a time when the open web was
starting to mature enough that you could
do everything without software without
plug-in installations and the big design
decision here that is different than
what people are doing in MOOCs and other
things should not have user accounts is
that I wanted to have minimal friction
to using this even if it means we don't
track as much data we can't track as
fine as fine grained we can deal without
with surveys and other things the second
thing is because again once we had
situate the open web really simple
feature turn up your effective is to
generate a snapshot URL so all the state
can be encapsulated in just the you know
and just a get request here so you can
generate a URL and then if I it or
whatever and you can end up spreading
this virally so you're on a MOOC and you
want help in something and you say hey
look check out this visualization I'm
starting a play with can you help me
with it or you I am this to a friend and
this is a way that it spreads not only
you can get help but if someone is in a
MOOC forum or money stackoverflow and
these online courses they see a link to
Python tutor com blah blah blah some
visualization they think Oh what is this
Python tutor say and they go and use it
in book market and spread it other way
it spreads again very standard for the
in the web era is embedding so you can
generate JavaScript code or iframes to
easily embed these live visualizations
and code editors and anything else so
people have embedded this in MOOCs
embedded this in digital textbooks and
again spread it really organically
the last thing about scale is more about
longevity is the fact that I've made
this I started this with Python as the
site shows as the site name shows but I
started thinking about how do we make
this into a more general platform for
visualizing things in other languages
because you know I there's no guarantee
that Python is going to be a popular
teaching language in five or ten years
or so but I want this platform to keep
living on and evolving and the way to do
so is to to have a more modular graphics
vocabulary engine so I implement this
grammar graphics which is a classic idea
from digitalization and adapted it for
the purposes of visualizing what goes on
inside of computers while code is
running for some design inspiration I
flip through many many books so if you
look through text books and programming
books that have diagrams in them in all
sorts of languages you'll find that the
graph will go vocabulary is actually
reasonably limited so they have these
box and pointer diagrams they have these
things stack they have nested boxes and
layouts and such and I came up with a
fairly parsimonious grammar there's more
details inside but basically what it has
has an idea of a memory block which has
an address that you can point to and an
inside there's either a primitive or a
collection of things a primitive is what
you normally think of and language a
number or a string also an image can be
a primitive because we're on the open
web so you can imagine if your
programming language or your your
environment is manipulating pictures you
could have those be elements in your
visualization there's no reason why we'd
have to stick with static strings a
collection is simply a list of blocks
along with a layout that shows the tells
engine how to lay them out so these are
horizontal vertical grid tree graph
these cover that kinds of data
structures you want to render and
because collections have blocks and
blocks of collections you can get this
nesting you also have an ID of a pointer
that join things together so how do we
use this grammar to to implement stuff
for new language so at a super high
level view of the graphics engine is
from the users perspective you're
writing code on the site you are running
it on the server using some kind of
tracer this tracer has to be written for
each language because you have to be
able to parse and execute and process
that language so here are some examples
Python uses the debugger ruby has some
kind of API for tracing code and C and
uses thing called valgrind which
instruments binaries so once you have
the trace this actually runs the code
and produces some data structure that's
everything that happened when your code
is running the stack the heap the values
the types these are all specific to the
language so the other thing you need a
part of this equation is some kind of
spec that the creator of the tool writes
once and this spec roughly says how do
you map pythons data structures into
Rosetta's grammar that you saw in the
previous slide or how do you map the
seed instructors in the grammar you put
those two together in a step and you
create a seeing graph and that the
vocabulary and the scene graph is the
grammar that I show in the previous
slide and then you can run it through
rendering paths as usual so HTML for web
page you can if you want to render a
book you can do PDF if you want to do
audio rendering which I think will be a
cool thing for accessibility you can
render this representation in any way
you want you know why go through all
this indirection and abstraction is
because we want to separate out the
language specific from the language
agnostic part so everything below is
language agnostic so we can reuse so in
effect that makes it easy to add new
languages because all you have to do is
add a new tracer and add a new spec to
map those language values into Rosetta's
generic grammars i've implemented for
seven languages so far and it's at this
point it's fairly routine it's just
routine engineering work to add more and
you can be really flexible in choosing
abstractions that have time to go
through all the pictures but you really
as the creator of this tool for your
language you get to choose the level
abstraction you want and how you show
diagrams so as a result of this kind of
combination of engineering design work
and and timing that coincided with
online education coming up about there's
been a tremendous amount of usage for
this project so the y-axis shows
pieces of visualize code so every time
someone is running the code and hitting
visualize there's it goes in the y-axis
so it's been out about three years now
so every day there are tens of thousands
of pieces of code visualized by 5,000
plus users what's more interesting to me
beyond just pure numbers is the breadth
of usage from people around the world so
we have people from almost every country
this is a dense density the only
thing that's missing
as Central Africa due to likely lack of
good internet acces so I put some simple
user demographic surveys on the site and
it turns out that over half the people
are non college or k12 age right these
are people over 25 years old interesting
about six of them are over 55 so they're
kind of like mrs. Hamilton person there
that these are really are people around
the world of all age groups who are
learning in various ways taking online
courses may be self teaching and using
this as a tool to supplement their
learning so some user survey excerpts of
how people use this there there's plenty
more on the web is you know it allows me
to visualize the code step by step and
to see what what are different
components and often code get triggered
I always wondered this and this tools
helped me understand this better than
any other resources this idea of
building the mental models by surfacing
with underneath debugging use case I
love it because it draws up the scope of
things going on making concepts like
mutability easier to understand also
like for general troubleshooting was
traced through the code in what is
actually going on compared to what I
think should happen so what have we
learned from work on this project first
the kind of key idea here is that's
surfacing what I call procedural state
what is going on inside the machine at
some appropriate level abstraction is
useful for both building mental models
and also for debugging code and
correcting the skin understandings that
designing for scale made it so far the
most widely used tool for this sort of
visualization and many decades of prior
work and that the obvious kind of next
step for this platform is to start
deploying more controlled experiments to
measure these learning effects more
concretely so so in these lab studies
people have shown kind of learning
effects in the lab that you know these
are visualizations are an effective
thing but you know online we have not
shown this that's question is this
architectural a design for scale in
terms of the back end or front end I
kind of mean it more an abstract way of
the kind of features I showed you about
you know not requiring accounts about
being able to be modular extended
different languages having the URL
sharing everything I mean this is not
Facebook scale right so the back end
doesn't need to we can do very standard
things so that
that isn't really too innovative it's
yeah it's more about thinking about
longer term usage yeah so the next
really obvious thing to do is think
about really controlled experiments and
we have this platform with thousands of
people on it every day to really start
measuring learning effects and retention
effects and such and we have a platform
by which to launch that now so in this
design space here where I would put this
is that as an improvement over these
static online materials that the ability
to visualize procedural state gives you
bit of more fidelity at least than
reading say PDF or watching a video and
thinking beyond programming can
surfacing this step-by-step procedural
state help people learn other soft
subjects right learn math or physics so
you can imagine math and physics being
amenable the similar idea of decomposing
things into steps or doing proofs or
those things what about law so you know
legal documents are these dozens of
pages of dense dense text what about
visualizing that so some people have
started manually doing this of kind of
encouraging design of more visual sorts
of legal briefs and I think there's
opportunities to try to think about
using NLP or things to automatically
extract logical sort of statements from
from legal documents and try to surface
those as well but there's still a
problem I mean so far there's still no
human the loops right so mrs. Hamilton's
original frustrations have not been met
yet that there's still no person helping
her along she can see these
visualizations just fine but uh she's
needs someone to explain them to her so
to start addressing this issue I've I
create this tool cut coachella and I had
to my master students help me run a a
case study on it last year for
inspiration I went to the computer lab
so this is a typical computer lab in any
school you see a lot of pair programming
and debugging going on you see a lot of
pointing to the screen and talking about
shared context and people draw diagrams
as well because the computer by default
doesn't draw them so again how can we
scale this up and in particular here the
question is how can we bring these in
lab interactions that are really high
fidelity high-touch kind of pair
programming collaborative learning
interactions to people who can't
actually meet up face to face and
to start addressing this question I
built this tool called Coachella which
is the first multi-user visualization
system that's an extension on the
Rosetta platform so here's a demo this
is the Rosetta site 500 calm you can
write code visualize you can visualize
everything and if you need help click
this button up here and if your tutor is
in a MOOC halfway around the world you
send them this URL and then they join
your session so they're you know
somewhere in the other part of the world
and you see multiple cursors you see
their cursor all your actions are
synchronized as well I think you can
just chat and embed a box like that and
then you can add a code there's a
collaborative editor all built in the
site so what this is trying to do is
start to emulate the sort of interaction
that people have in lab except you can
be anywhere doing this so ideas about
designing for scale so first of all it's
built on top of the Rosetta platform
which has already been scalable by this
time and the main things that I added
were just the machinery and the backend
for synchronizing cursors and stayed in
chat and everything just like it's using
Rosetta joining the session now is as
simple as joining a web URL no
installation no screen sharing software
it's really lightweight you're just
doing a write in your browser so you can
just send it to someone in the forum the
multiple cursors are really lightweight
way to emulate some sort of presence so
you can actually see people waving
around saying look look here and finally
text chat is more scalable than say
doing something like video both for
bandwidth reasons if you're halfway on
the world and also it's sort of a lower
barrier to entry things so that if
you're mrs. Hamilton in a MOOC you might
be kind of shy and not want to video
chat with a tutor around the world you
don't know but text chatting or you know
ready informed maybe okay the design
point of this tool is really for
one-on-one tutoring like this or small
groups you can imagine five people
entering a room together with five
cursors and chatting but you don't want
to scale this up too much more because
you're all sharing one session so some
questions about this is one can it bring
these in lab interactions to people who
cannot be to face-to-face and can people
actually learn and feel some sort of
human connection using this tool so
investigate these questions we we
deployed it to the website for about a
year and a half simply a button up here
there's a little FAQ but we did not do a
we didn't have any tasks or paid
recruitment we wanted to see we have all
these thousand people on the site and a
naturalistic way who are already
learning online would they make use of
this resource this additional resource
we put here in their naturalistic
learning and if so how would they do it
so the data shows that in fact it did
connect people who are remote which is
good so there are 740 sessions after we
filtered for gellick sessions that
weren't anything of substantive so these
are actually sessions where people were
actually chatting and interacting they
came from hundreds of cities dozens of
countries the important data point here
is that almost half the sessions were
multiple City ones so these are actually
people who found each other somehow
maybe on their MOOC maybe on some form
and we're working with each other and
one six or multiple times so obviously
these people could not have gotten
together next door and got over to each
other's um dorms to chat so this graph
is connecting countries if there's a
session where people participate in
those countries again because it's data
was all not in this no accounts we don't
know the detailed demographics these
people but I suspect that these we're
taking people taking online courses
together yes given your millions of
people on the site the 740 number yo how
does that relate um it is a bit on the
low end III I think that because I think
all we did we just put this button on
and said you know there's like an FAQ
here
we didn't advertise this in a particular
way there was no structure around him
and this is exactly the site so yeah I
mean I think these numbers are a bit low
but again we didn't you know we didn't
purposely try to pump up those numbers
or encourage instructor way like imagine
if this were deploy as part of a course
and there was a curricula around and
then we would have more controlled usage
yeah this is the the numbers are what
they are yeah it's a good question
alright so you know this is kind of a
naturalistic as kind of Michael question
earlier this is just in the wild this is
sort of the amount of usage we get and I
think part of the reason for the
percentage of sessions created over
total users being low is that we
actually don't have a way of connecting
people together currently you actually
have to know somebody to do this so not
everyone is going on the site so there's
kind of naturally preview some future
work it turns out that people interacted
like they would in lab so by coding
manually coding the chat logs for for
activity intent there are two things
that just two kinds activities judges
popped up really apparently from the log
so 101 tutoring which is one person is
clearly expert and working with someone
else and then peer learning which is two
or three or five people trying to figure
stuff out together there was about 40 60
split roughly evenly so this is a this
is sort of what you would see in lab
example log this is just the tutor
speaking so this is an example of a
pretty good tutor who is Socratic Li
narrowing down the space and helping the
learner debug and having learners answer
questions so we saw some really good
tutors on this we saw some tutors that
weren't as good a very a lot and future
work is think about how do we structure
the tutoring sessions peer learning was
you know there's two people here so
imagine two or three people hashing
something out together like you're
working on homework and you know peer
tutoring sessions a peer learning
sessions are a lot more tentative and
back and forth and you notice how people
actually interact with the visualization
so people appear to learn in sessions so
because again we're not doing a control
learning experiment we're doing in the
wild naturalist appointment they the
main thing we can say is whether the
chat logs indicated that some knowledge
was being transferred to get a sense of
how long these sessions were they were
you know dozens of minutes so this is
comparable to if you're sitting there
face-to-face with someone in front of a
computer about a chat every minute and
there's way more visualization
interactions than chat so this is
stepping running going backwards and
such so the by analyzing a chat log
they're both declarative and procedural
knowledge
was transferred declarative is what is
the syntax thing what does this mean to
procedural is let's step-by-step debug
this problem I'm at the lower three
levels of Bloom's taxonomy so Bloom's
taxonomy is a six level hierarchy that
shows increasing levels of
sophistication and knowledge has brand
we saw instances at these lower three
levels many of the instances of
knowledge transfer anchored to the
visualizations so there were things
where people were talking about things
are visualizing and playing with so
here's an example here you could read
that's pretty dense and it doesn't make
much sense if you don't see the picture
right this is the sort of conversation
you can only have if you're seeing a
picture in front of you and going back
and forth and pointing to it so that's
kind of the value added having a picture
and and the text at the same time so
people also bonded emotionally again
with the chat blog so there was these
effective exchanges that promoted
motivation things friendly banter
showings of camaraderie also
encouragement especially in tutoring
sessions so learner says oh my god I'm
so terrible I'm sorry tutor says not a
problem at all you've written little
code yet it'll take a while for it to
come more comfortable so we definitely
saw these technicals I'm gonna go
technical talk and then there's some
emotional bonding thing and the more
technical stuffs this is very different
than say if you were just getting
automated hints from from from a system
so what if you learn that first this
real-time substrate for discussing
procedural state can be an effective
substitute for people who otherwise
can't get together face to face right
that you probably want to get together
face to face if you can but if you can't
then this starts emulating some of these
benefits but more interestingly than the
half the population who were in
different cities actually in a third of
the sessions it was being used even by
people who were knew each other in real
life the way we coded for this is this
to their indicators that they knew each
other they're like we're gonna go to
this party tonight or this class is you
know terrible or whatever or you know
when is study hall and then we're using
this tool they're electing to use this
tool even when they could obviously Bend
together and this is um this classic HCI
concept design concept being beyond
being there which is that you know
thinking about how do we design system
that people would prefer to use even
when they could just physically go to
each other in real life and I think this
idea of discussing what's underneath
contributes to that yes
providing technological brekkie like
co-president scenario I'm wondering what
was it about Coachella that was better
than being there right so it's a great
question like Michaels question yeah
pieces here is that if we design them
they're happy some value add in the
technology so that that's better than
just face to face and I think the big
thing is this idea of discussing
procedural state that we are uncovering
the pictures automatically so we can you
know we can talk about it rather than
having you manually say draw them
yourself the comparison is not
necessarily to not having Python tutor
it's to having Python tutor on my
computer and you're sitting next to my
right so why are we using it in two
different locations is it just it's more
convenient because I'm in my dorm room
and you're in yours or is there
something that this is actually
providing beyond sitting next to each
other in the lab music yeah that's a
great question I think part of it part
of it is that it is this lightweight
thing that you could kind of integrate
into your I'm already sitting in my dorm
computering and then this is just a
lightweight thing rather than physically
going somewhere but I should think about
this more offline but I was thinking
more of it in terms of not having you
know the base case of of this yeah but I
think you're this really good point yep
situation we'll see what is the fact of
us both be able to try right while
sitting next to each other and
communicate easily verbally oh is that
worse or better than the Sham round
situation with people who studied a lot
earlier with kids learning situation we
could definitely do in the lab like we
have they like both your points we have
this thing and we just put them in lab
co-located using it there are people who
did this a few years ago in person with
some kind of simpler visualization
system and one of their findings I can
dig up the paper
their findings is that being able to
talk about the visualization at least in
person gave people that sort of teamwork
comradery sense they gave people that
the benefits were more social of having
them feel closer to classmates and
perhaps we don't get that as much in the
online setting cool so thing is that
these spontaneous effective exchanges
show this interface can humanize online
learning this is not just about let's
just exchange facts of this this sort of
even if we have a low bandwidth chat we
could people actually are engaging in
ways that are non non technical so what
Coachella is trying to do is to push out
this this scale factor right so we have
lower fidelity than face-to-face but
we're scaling a bit better because we
don't need a person there you know in
person we can be online thinking beyond
programming so can this idea of
synchronized procedural state Foster
real-time critique and see a virtual art
or design see where people are working
on these procedural tasks so if you're
sculpting or doing some kind of visual
art if we could say instrument the room
or instrument these you know these metal
scaffolding everything and be able to
project your real time state can can
someone remotely tutor you and critique
you doing this whereas right now this
sort of visual art and design stuff has
been very much in person but there is a
problem that came up when we were doing
this project which is pretty obvious in
retrospect which is that the tutor there
aren't that many tutors available right
so if you're in a MOOC or an online
setting here mrs. Hamilton you can use
this to summon a tutor you ask for help
this is great for you you have a
personal tutor there but the tutor it's
a lot more limited because they can only
help one person at once because they are
they are bound through this one-on-one
tutoring situation and what if the tutor
wants to help five students or ten
students or side they have to open up
five or ten tabs and switch between them
and that the tutor attention is really
the bottleneck to further scaling up
being able to provide real time help
online is that because they're way fewer
tutors and learners so how can a single
tutor help more learners at once and
that leads into the system I created
called code Opticon which has nothing to
do with Turk optic on the similar name
that I presented with a few months ago
once again for design inspiration I went
back to the computer lab and this time
instead of looking at the students
working I looked at the instructors or
their lab tutors the ideal thing for
them is to provide timely and targeted
help which is someone raises their hand
and they go up to them and they provide
a targeted assistance right away when
the context is is fresh proactive help
is also really important because what a
really good tutor will be able to do is
to scan the room and be situationally
aware of how people are doing and if
someone looks like they're really stuck
or frustrated to go up to them and and
offer assistance many learners are
either shy and they don't want to ask
for help
or they're too fixated on debugging
something and they don't know when they
should step back that's the ideal
reality doesn't really match that right
if you have twenty to one ratio thirty
to one fifty to one there are just way
more students in the lab than tutors so
it's a best-effort scramble it's
physically exhausting to run around the
lab and you know if you have lab hours
for an hour it's actually really tiring
to run around so how can a single tutor
help more learners at once without
suffering from as much fatigue and I
wanted to address this question not only
for the in lab case so this is great if
you're building a tool that can help
tutors you know save some save some
exertion from running around a physical
lab but I want to think about scales I
wanted to design something that not only
works in person but also works in this
online case of your own a MOOC or in
Khan Academy or in some online learning
platform you may have a hundred so
people online at once working in various
ways and you want to be able to help
them in real time so I made a system
called code opticon which is the first
one to many tutor interface so how it
works roughly is leave a tutor on their
computer and they're monitoring a group
of learners in real time as they're
coding to show how this works I'm going
to show you a super simple example which
is just one tutor and one learner on
here on the left side is the learners
code editor so this can be implemented
in any say web-based editor I put it on
the Rosetta site because that's the
platform that I that I have and the
right side is the tutors view so this
video will play twice first look at the
left side for the learner and then the
whole thing will play again I gotta look
at the right side of the teacher so
learners on the site trying to write a
program
for homework so product function XY is
arguments and I know they change their
mind Amb is arguments okay I do return a
product you use the X sine figure that's
what it looks like a math and when you
try to compile and run it there's some
bizarre error that it's not helpful so
maybe it's a lower case X okay play the
same thing again now look at the bright
side for the tutor the tutor sees the
learners action streaming in in chunks
and nearly in real time so Green as diff
for adding and a flashing red shows
deletion so this way the tutor can see
what the learners I'm doing and then
when they run their code if they see the
error right away and the change and
another error okay so now they can
actually go in history slider and just
go backwards and see the chunks of what
the learner was doing and compiling and
running I'm just back and forth to try
to get some contacts and then they can
just start a chat that's a private
inline chat with the learner and this
pops up and they can have a private
one-on-one chat now
so in sum the tutors view of one learner
is to summarize in this tile of their
compiling and edit activities with
history and chat side of the scale up to
more than one learner the interface is
pretty straightforward is we just put it
in a grid so this is on a laptop you
have about ten spots if you have a big
computer map 15 a big monitor the first
thing here is that this is easily
deployable yeah modulo some engineering
work is that the learner can use their
existing interface so their programming
Rosetta or they're on coke atom II or on
some Mook we have two instrument that
interface that that code to send the
data to the tutor real time but they're
just working on the original ID it's not
like they have to go to some special
thing just to use this this is deployed
on existing sites there's a history
slider to restore contacts is really
important because as you can imagine you
can't actually see everybody working in
real time because there's so many people
you can only attend to probably a few of
one so if you miss something you can
just quickly slide back and get the
context you can start a text chat with
anybody you want and just open up these
multiple text chats with each one of
these are private one-on-one chats as
though you're helping someone privately
and of course the obvious question is
what if they're more than ten learners
so you can imagine more people joining
and down here and piling down so if you
have a hundred people and people coming
in and out then you're gonna have to
scroll a lot but the main observation is
especially in an online setting
people have very wildly different levels
activity you someone may be watching a
video another tab or going on Facebook
and some going to be frantically trying
to edit and in debug in getting errors
so we have a pretty simple heuristic
that periodically reshuffles around some
tiles to to bubble up the learners who
are most recently active and then when
they become inactive they get pushed
down and the idea is that the tutors
main field of view they're seeing the
people who are most recently doing
things and this is a very simple
heuristic and it's work reasonably well
in the first pass but there's many ways
to improve this heuristic right here so
the questions that everyone is thinking
about is one the most obvious one is how
many people can actually someone handle
using this interface to is can they
successfully help learners and three is
how does how do they feel this compares
to a real
a tutoring situation to find out I did a
study that was both in the lab and
online so the tutors were in lab
physically in lab bate subjects of one
at a time just one person sitting from
the computer at time this is a staff
from the intro course that all held
these lab hours this is exactly the
target population these are the people
who would walk around doing doing lab
hours first time using the tool I just
said spend 30 give them tutorials that
spend 30 minutes helping anonymous
learners on the Rosetta website and
whatever way you feel most comfortable
so again we wanted to see you have to
emulate what they would have done in lab
normally this there was no kind of tasks
or quotas that you must help five people
and it half an hour whatever the people
online knew during the session that they
were being monitored and their actions
are all being monitored but but they
weren't expecting them the proactive
help so this is akin to the customer
service case where you're browsing a
website and someone pops up and says it
looks like you're buying shoes and not
exercising most evil close the tab or
they didn't speak English because it
came from hundreds of the countries that
didn't understand it so this really this
simple sort of first study is really a
worst case scenario because if you were
really to use this tool and you know in
a real way the tutors would know how to
use the tool and the learners know about
it and we have saved virtual office
hours but so let's see how they did even
given this anonymous scenario what each
squiggly line is one session so they're
eight of them this is how many learners
are online at once so they hover around
fifty at once every 30 minutes session
about 200 people came in and out so this
is because his online site people are
going coding and then closing the tab or
leaving our stuff this is around the
range of people being monitored so a few
dozen in a MOOC maybe there'll be a few
more maybe a hundred or so notice that
most people went over the 30-minute time
limit and that gets into this question
here of how did the tutors feel while
they're using this interface the biggest
feeling they reported both from their
actions in their their think aloud was
that they felt this great feeling of
immersion that they felt that first was
sonís in this foreign kind of interface
but they really got into it pretty fast
after about the first few minutes of
looking around everybody pretty much
went over the time limit they didn't
show any visible signs of fatigue or
overload even though I didn't like strap
an EEG on their head
but they they felt this was enough that
they could just keep going just like a
lab hour also they said this is way less
tiring than having to physically run
around they're sitting at their desk it
turns out you know as expected they
selectively attended to things I didn't
do eye tracking but the mouse tracking
is reasonable because they kind of you
can kind of see people's mice going to
certain places authenticity was a big
thing they report as well that they felt
like they were tutoring in real life
with their real personalities and style
shows so some people were a lot more
reticent some people were a lot more
proactive jumping in and trying to help
people and the way in which they engage
with learners differed as well how does
this compare to in-person tutoring big
advantages were they can control their
own pace better so they reported they
loved having a dashboard to have
situational awareness so they could see
what was going on and selectively help
people instead of people raising their
hand and them running around frantically
the history slider is super helpful ism
they can't get in real life that they
really liked and they could help about
it turns I think helped about three
people at once so this is a log of how
many chat windows they had opened
concurrent conversations so they kind of
some people started off slow and chatted
into a chatter right away it's around
two or three at once and this this
number kind of makes sense because what
happens is when you're helping someone
they're not responding usually in
real-time you give them out of him you
get asked him a question they go off for
a while do something so it's nice to
have this dashboard so you can help
somebody else that's the question if you
see five people are having to siak same
error you may want to broadcast that's
not currently the system but we could
definitely implement this the reason why
I didn't think about this for the
original version was that I wanted to
assume kind of in the wild situation
where everyone was working presumably on
different problems or at their own pace
but you can imagine if you deployed this
in a class in a lab hour saying we are
all working on merge sort now start and
you all have the same context we could
do that and we could do even really
cooler things with clustering and other
stuff when we have the same context
that's a great that's a great idea
disadvantages people complain that text
was too low bandwidth there is these
small text boxes I mean you can't really
get really deep there and now they were
afraid that reshuffling may piano
learners who were actually stuck and
sitting there but not active that's the
that that prioritize activity has that
drawback one way a simple way to fix
this is in a production version of this
is to have a get held button so the
learners can summon the tutor privately
for help and that's a signal that they
need help what the learners do in these
sessions so about two to three learners
confirm help in each 30-minute session
that's them saying you know blah blah
blah thanks you fix my problem or like
oh I really wish I had this this is
despite the fact that these are
completely unsolicited so in a you know
a real class situation huh that's right
that's right we injected those as well
actually some of the ones I love to go
behind some of the ones you know they're
asking are you a bot alright I said yes
yeah they said no yeah it turns out if
you start to generic people think you're
a bot or if you're like oh do you need
help on this then they might actually
think you're a blonde whereas if you are
more targeted so it's interesting some
of the users they started off not
getting good responses then they try to
think of how do we pass the Turing test
here by itself and and actually help
them better both types of knowledge
again this time at the lower two levels
in loop taxonomy and here are some
examples of these are mostly kind of
language or runtime specific things they
were helping with so this is typical the
sort of beginner errors you're helping
people debug so a tutor it ends up being
real moderate a few dozen learners to
help out three at once
um again with this VM being their point
is that pretty much everyone said that
they wanted this tool even for there in
person courses and and a big benefit
they said was that you know they just
didn't want to run around they don't
want to run around live and they wanted
to be able to have feel more control
over their tutoring and this idea of
process history and surfacing it can
start overcoming some of the limitations
of real time modern multiple people so
just a simple idea of having a history
slider really helps a lot because you
don't have histories then you have to
really see what goes on real time and
that's not gonna that's not gonna scale
and the beside despite this low
bandwidth chat the tutors found it to be
immersive and an authentic experience
for doing the sort of light lab style
kind of
Proactive tutoring up so what Coachella
Co topogun does is push out on the scale
even more right so it goes from one to
one to one to many and thinking beyond
programming so what if everybody could
watch everybody else working all the
time right what if we had a co-op to
come for every student so you know
intellectual honesty issues and copying
code issues notwithstanding you know
what can we gain from actually seeing
what other people in the class are doing
you know this this reminds me of sue my
wife is a dentist you actually trained
at UCSF just a few minutes up in San
Francisco and they have these labs where
they just have a hundred stations with
physical apparatuses and computers and
everything we have instructors and a
student is just roaming around looking
at what each other is doing and can we
think about how to do this online and we
can even do better online because we
have histories in other sorts an
invisible state they don't have them
person the you know the problem that
came up when working on could go to
optical art and coach all built the
systems is that we're presuming that
there are tutors available right you're
producing there's some situation where
there's someone there to help you but
what if there are is nobody available in
the worst case scenario and for that we
turn to the fellow learners so if
there's no tutors available what about
if you summon other learners for help so
on the Rosetta site we get about 60 ish
people up to about a hundred depending
on time these are people online at at
once and a MOOC there may be around 100
so here are some you know starts of some
ideas for how do you leverage the crowd
so I have a student Mitchell Gordon
whose work of me we had one paper come
out with some preliminary results on
this but can we have the crowd create
tutorial so can we put a piece of code
on a skit about something about runtime
semantics format for the people who are
currently on the site and have them be
able to now run the code and surface the
internal details and see what's going on
and make annotations of what they think
is happening and then do the usual
cloudy things of voting and filtering
and aggregation and and can they come up
with reasonable tutorials that turns out
for simple basic kind of cs1 examples
they do a reasonable job now the thing
is peer tutoring so we have all these
dozen people online can we match them up
to each other and make suggestions for
them to help each other because they're
no 2x
available so we could use things like
their activity level their skill level
based on with their editing so you can
say like oh looks like you're working on
like lists would you like to work
together Bob or Carol we're also
struggling or lick lists so you know yes
looks like you're struggling with linked
lists or maybe you can help developer
Carol
you what obviously there's Tonica you
know hand-waving here how do you not
make this into chatroulette or something
you know pulling this managed but the
crowd is there so this again pushes it
out to from one too many too many too
many so you know so there's some up
really what what's going on here that we
really want to provide some like mrs.
Hamilton with more than just these
static online materials right so if she
can't get face-to-face we really want in
the future in these online learning
environments to provide a spectrum of
options depending on can trade-off of
fidelity and scale I presented these
cases for programming here but we can
imagine generalizing these ideas to
learning other skills if you could think
about how to visualize things and how to
surface the histories the ideal here
obviously is high fidelity at high scale
so what does that mean maybe it means
mobile wearables because more people
will just have them with them at all
times maybe it means higher fidelity
things like VR or even brain-computer
interfaces so yeah these these are kind
of wild blue sky ways to think about
this but you know so far we've had to
make this trade-off so in sum the
question I started with is how do we
scale up the benefits of face-to-face
learning online an approach I've taken
in this talk is to by surfacing
procedural state what's going on
step-by-step inside of some black box
and then also surfacing the history and
then fostering an environment where you
can do real-time monitoring and chat so
that people are actually engaged in a
real-time and to put this much more
simply it's actually a really simple
idea which is to surface invisible and
then talk about so just find out some
way to surface what's going on
underneath the covers and let people
talk about those things so that they
have a much more richer conversation
than just talking about say the code and
I've shown this for programming but I
think there's these things can apply
kind of physical design activities for
things like medical education and even
for something as remote as law where you
know everything's vertex space and
inherently not visual and with that I'd
like to include my talk and I'd be happy
to take more questions I'm around so I'd
be happy to take more questions as well
so thank you I'll be very interested to
see what your scheduling solution is
getting several people then it's also
spread out over a 24-hour clock yeah
sometimes you have to make like schedule
times for this and it gets really
flu-like you'd like to just service the
invisible you and sometimes you have to
like force the structure to work so I
don't know you just kind of like a large
volume yeah that's an open challenge
I mean the question of even if you have
hundreds of people there are different
time zones they have different contexts
um
one way to think about this is you know
I'm proposing something totally
synchronous real-time the existing state
of the art in a MOOC is totally
asynchronous is a forum what do you
think about this is bridging the two
right so I think something only designed
things like facebook Messenger I like or
slack where you can chat in real time
but it's also kind of persistent so you
can come back in an hour and and talk as
well so imagine something I designed
that that bridges that I think I think
maybe one way to scale across time yeah
it's useful structure forced people to
like get something ready before the
deadline I'm positive yeah I think this
could be used as the basis for these
more structure activities like talk
about it and things cool one back um did
you try this with very large programs
list of all the examples
when I tried it out it was really
collection I'm curious like if you have
like a hundred black yeah that's a great
question so the thing that I totally
didn't cover is the scalability of the
visualizations themselves so the way to
think about that model is this is what
you would draw on a board so you
probably don't want to debug something
with a million nodes on you know because
you can't draw on the board so there's
two issues is how long the code is and
also how complex the runtime state is so
you could have 100 lines of code but
it's generating only a few objects and
the objects are changing and that's
that's fine but in general I would say
50 lines of code at most with maybe a
dozen or two dozen objects because
beyond that you can't even hope to draw
it on the board so you have to make
something smaller that's a good question
yes question I was wondering in the
future if you thought it'd be useful
direction to let the people who are
coming up with the curriculum for a MOOC
or something create their own custom
visualizations like so if you're
teaching an OS class which is not like
five line codes like you could just have
like a big box for like this part of the
OS and like a big box for this part of
the OS and let the instructor like come
up with their own ways of visualizing it
yes custom visualizations that
instructors can create and I was
starting to get into that with the
Rosetta that graphical grammar idea so
you can imagine extending that grammar a
bit more generally to components and
boxes and diagrams and stuff and then
you have this sort of spec so that you
know Insano s class you have some
library that someone is writing your I
don't know your thread scheduling code
ed and by calling these functions the
visualization knows that to render this
function is to use a box or arrows or
whatever and then you could have the
same ideas yeah so I think those will be
very domain-specific but we can think
about generalizing that even more but
yeah so so far I've just throws
Enterbrain that's a great great
direction yes connected it seems like
you know so far in the world what's
really taking off right are these pro or
a lot of classes that are around the
tops of computer science because
obviously they went
so it's very well and being visualized
on a 2d computer stream and so looking
at other engineering disciplines for
example things like mechanical
engineering there's many many or less
less or fewer anyway there are less
horses of these other disciplines
because I think you know it's it's
harder to capture maybe a Freebody
diagram and be able to run through it
step by step so have you got it guys
thought a little bit about looking at
these other visualization that might
work well for more spatial information
yeah other questions other topics oh
yeah immediately comes in mind is we
want to start with 2d and then imagine
you know 3d CAD like things I haven't
looked into personally myself and my
suspicion is that you know given the
right design and instrumentation you can
do it cuz I don't know about how these
are programmed if it's some declarative
language if it's some kind of you know
they're a log thing or you know with
circuits I mean often used in education
underlying things that are more similar
to like you talked about in the
beginning like physics as it's like
having you know you have these
misconceptions about physics similarly
you know those to these other
engineering yeah you may want to like a
direct manipulation or face for creating
these things or so there's these
microworlds thing in physics where you
can drag blocks and Springs and then run
a physical simulation of that so maybe
that's perhaps Pharma that people can
and to surface that you have you know
time steps right it's like you can step
through time and see the ball
accelerating or each frame there it's
going down even more the spring is
accelerant are decelerating yeah I mean
people like Brett Victor have looked
into these sorts of expanding time into
space sorts of visualization so then
this is all super interesting to go into
it for a future work though there's a
lot in programming and I think that even
more broadly that Sean's point is that
without like 3d like like physical world
things like
this right like this is even way harder
as I do do camera
dirty' do you know do you have smart
materials oh those are really open do
you see any possibility of sort of using
that model to sort of train more
automated consistent where you started
to gradually question her who is about
taking those interaction traces both
with code and debug and also with chat
right we have chat human annotated you
know things about the code and using
them to train see machine learning or a
train program analysis or synthesis tool
I think that's also an awesome other
awesome direction and the way you know
as an HDI person I don't want to put
people out of work so the way I would
diplomatically bridge that is to say
that these tools can help triage and
augment people even more so imagine that
code Opticon thing where since the tutor
can't help everybody at once the simpler
kind to help
we can get you started with a triage
with and why is the like thing that
starts asking you how you're feeling
about the weather or you know how you're
feeling about this part of the code did
you look at the first line second line
people who also we're doing this we're
looking in this line of code and then as
it gets conversation started maybe the
human can jump in to do the thoughts you
know the more AI complete sort of things
but yeah the data traces are definitely
there and that's totally under exploited
right now and I would it's another giant
area I would love to look into you and
Sunday about the mapping between the
underlying programming I was wondering
what you thought like maybe those
potential avenues for beyond using the
visualization to help represent what's
going on whether there's ways to use the
visualization interactively you
mentioned right Victor just sounded like
to help teach the underlying concepts so
like maybe more direct many times like
in a scratch suit style yeah you know
when I say interacting now it's really
just stepping back and forth and seeing
it but what about actually be able to
grab the visualizations and put stuff in
place um
yeah yeah we're going the other way
right like visual one the immediate
thing that comes up the meet it next
step
adjacent there is to do active learning
activities so the first step is seeing
visualization you built the right model
and then you fade away that scaffold and
you say here's my code here's an
incomplete diagram drag the parts that
should be there in and will tell you if
you're right and so turning the
visualizations into an activity could
give you more active learning and
engagement that way so that's that's one
you know short-term thing a long-term
thing is you know can you imagine
learning a program with more visual
paradigm rather than wearing the syntax
which other yeah as you said other
people looked into as well yep lots of
tutors did you ever think about it's
kind of controversial but like charging
or paying for being it or getting paid
to be a tutor or even gain the firing of
it so yeah like you're the top tutor
reserves I mean some kind of a list they
can draw from that's a recognition all
right so my question is about both
paying tutors or gamifying and building
this you know stack overflow like karma
community leaderboard thing I think the
the paying thing I'm a I'm less inclined
to do because I think that it's it I I
think I want to draw on people's
intrinsic motivation of your on the site
learning and wanting to help people
similar that why people were posting on
the MOOC form the I want to draw on that
sort of motivation rather than make it
into a more traditional paid micro cast
kinda crowdsourcing sorta situation and
for the gamification thing I think
that's something to look into as well
I'm I'm a bit afraid of people you know
I think communities that are geared on
gamification you know I like second
we'll have issues with exclusion and and
not being as friendly to beginners or
people wanting to game it and and gain
that way and such but yeah that's still
very much in the future work section and
I think we have to have some elements of
that but I you know I want to avoid
money for now because I want to see how
far can we push if we don't pay people
because you know people voluntarily do
this because it maybe help them learn as
well
cool one more how are you on time it's
140 let's take one last one of them all
okay one last one yep
I really like your strategy of like
looking at the real-world situations and
and trying to master things on it tear
the programs that you wrote how did you
go about like deciding like this is
something that happens in the real world
that we want to replicate because it's
really great versus something that you
would want to change because in the end
you're trying to make something that's
better right in the real world yeah
that's a that's a deep question I'm
trying to think of I don't have a great
answer off the bat but the way to the
way I approach it is at first we want to
at least get these common best bracketed
what happening in lab one at leas get
those online and in the process we can
think about things like history or or
diagrams or you know multiple you know
multiplexing to make it slightly better
you know the other part of that question
I do what kind of undesirable things in
the real world do we not want to
replicate online and part of that is why
I did kind of a lower bandwidth text
sort of things so you know if we let's
say we had try to really replicate the
real world and have video for all the
boxes instead of text and I think that
it would be much harder for people to
use it because they feel more ashamed or
more shy or so yeah so there were
decisions of yeah both for scalability
and also for you know wanting people to
use that to actually step a step back
from the real world awesome questions
you